joining us now is our dr. Jon LaPook
John good morning morning this is now
the second high-profile suicide this
week and just here everyone's saying wow
what is what is going on here we just
had this new study that says suicide
rates are up what's happening they're up
25 percent in the last decade and and a
lot of very smart people are looking at
this and saying it's multifactorial we
don't really understand why there's such
an increase the risk factors are things
like social isolation if you're in
trouble in terms of alcohol abuse or
drug abuse of course a history of
depression or previous suicide or even
family history of suicide but one of the
things that we keep coming back to when
these surprising events happen is you
never know what is in somebody's head
and so how do you know a lot of times
people who end up committing suicide
even when they're asked are you suicidal
they'll say no I'm not
would you consider this a public health
crisis and if so how what does that mean
exactly in terms of way we should think
about this I think it is a public health
crisis and I think what it means is that
we need more resources we need more
research when you have something that's
increasing and smart people are looking
at it and saying what is going on here
you know there's no other you know we
know that when there's mosquito seasons
you get more mosquito bites but what is
going on here to cause this increase and
we do have a society we have to all say
where there is apparently more social
isolation and this you know one of the
things that is so tragic and and then
people beat themselves up about it is
this is such that this can be such an
impetuous event you know I one of the
things in the CDC report that came out
yesterday I read through it it said that
in more than half of deaths in 28 27
states the people had no known mental
health condition when they ended their
lives is it that perhaps they should
have been seeking treatment and they
they weren't that maybe more people need
preventative care preventive care and
more outreach you know doctors I think
have been criticized because we don't go
into that you know if somebody may have
15 minutes for a visit and and the
doctor may be the one person who really
knows you for all those years and the
person really trusts you go into it go
into the direct questions that you can
ask to try to elicit it but it's a very
tough thing when studies show that often
people will deny it we do have to say
that gun guns accounted for about half
of the 45,000 deaths it can be an
impetuous
event that if you can just get over it
and then get treatment that maybe you
can try to avoid it and get some help
you talk warning signs I mean what are
the indicators what should people be
looking for yeah and that is what people
kick themselves afterwards when when
there were and no apparent warning signs
but the ones that are written about our
social isolation in engaging in risky
behavior so drug use alcohol use a
history of not only depression but
suicidal ideation saying not only am I
kind of thinking about suicide but
here's how I'm gonna do it a family
history of it all so I mean you're an
internist you see patients you hear more
people saying I'm suffering from
depression and anxiety I'd certainly
hear people saying they're more anxious
in recent years and yes with depression
I'm very aggressive with this I actually
spend a bunch of time talking to people
it's usually towards the end when
they're feeling more comfortable you
know how's it going and all along I'm
sort of probing and finding out what
their mood is and I refer very very
often to psychiatrists other health
facilities to try to get people mental
health and also I try to say to them
look I'm here I may be the only person
in the world who you feel comfortable
talking to and there was some statistic
I may get it slightly wrong that said
that people who had committed suicide
about half of them had seen a doctor
within the previous six or twelve months
and so I think of myself like I may be
that lifeline I may be that who they
they feel comfortable I'll say look it's
you and me I promise you there's no
judgment tell me everything thank you
dr. Jon LaPook
anything